there are few people in the world or
even world history that you can just say
their last names and you'll know
automatically who they are you don't
need any more there that statue you may
think of Einstein Freud and dr. Spock
how many of you folks out there either
raised your children and the Spock Ian
manor or were raised in such a way
millions and millions but dr. Spock is a
significant person in the history of the
United States right Doug
not only in child care but in other
fields dr. Spock has been active in
anti-nuclear groups like saying for many
years he was a prominent spokesperson
for the Vietnam War he's one of the
first anti-war spokespersons I heard
when I was a student at Columbia
University and has continued to be
politically active through the years we
want to discuss all of these things with
him but we thought we'd start off with
discussing in your theories of child
care which is what got you famous and
made you a personality and national
figure in the first place could you
reflect a little bit on your book that
you published first in 1946 it's called
baby and child care and has gone through
several editions how did your theory of
child care differ from more traditional
theories and over the years how have you
modified that that's quite an order I
never thought of it as a theory I can
tell you where I got my ideas in the
first place I was brought up very
sternly and strictly by a New England
couple especially my fiercely moralistic
mother and though some people have said
I suppose this book as a protest against
the way you were brought up well that's
only about a third of it I think that my
interest in children devotion to
children and those of my sisters and
brother were all because my mother was
real totally devoted to her children so
I think that's part of where I got
launched from I cared a lot about that
children but I think I also thought
there were must be easier ways more
pleasant ways to bring children and the
rather severe oppressive way that my
mother used I had pediatric training at
the medical
cool and then I thought I've got to get
some psychological training no other
pediatrician had gotten that and stayed
in pediatrics so I found there was no
place to get this training so I took a
year's residency in psychiatry at New
York Hospital that was occupied taking
care of patients with schizophrenia and
manic depressive psychosis this gave me
nothing with which to add some others
questions about thumb-sucking and
toilet-training and resistance to
weaning but I did discover during that
year's residency that it was a
psychoanalytically trained two people
who were able to make the discussion of
patients stories dynamic so I said I
want psychoanalytic training so of that
year that I started pediatric practice
in New York at the bottom of the
depression in 1933 I started in my own
personal now assess and then for five
years took seminars a New York
psychoanalytic Institute this this
explains my Freudian my basically
Freudian
concepts and actually anyone who knows a
Freud reading through baby and childcare
sees Freud popping up again and again
not in Freud's words or with labeled the
Freud they're the more positive things
that you got out of fraud Freud was
interested in where is the origin of
neuroses I was interested in the other
side of it how the children grow
emotionally and I think Freud has given
us very good explanation of the stages
of development but it took me ten years
before I could reconcile my Freudian
concepts with what mothers were telling
me my Freudian training didn't tell me
it told me that sometimes you get into
terrible conflicts with a child of a
toilet training but when I asked my
psychoanalytic colleagues well when
should you start toilet training they
shrug their shoulders because of course
they didn't then
oh they only knew this our side of it so
I had to work out with the help of
dozens and dozens of mothers what is the
application I'd give them the best
advice I could on the basis of my
theoretical background and then the next
time they bring the baby in a month
later I'd say how did how'd it work and
I was constantly having to revise my
idea of what is the practical thing to
tell parents and what is the
relationship between that and theory
this was shown by the fact that five
years after I started practice doubleday
the publisher came to me and said we
would like you to write a book on child
care this wasn't because I was
well-known I was completely unknown but
they had asked questions around in New
York and found that I was the only
pediatrician with some training I told
them I don't know enough I was I was not
being modest or falsely modest I really
didn't know enough of the answers
pocketbooks came ten years after I
started practice the editor there said
he was a droll fella he said doesn't
have to be a very good book he said at
25 cents a copy we are going to be if
this was but yeah well I wasn't insulted
at all I think first of all the idea of
reaching a hundred thousand people per
year that seemed very worthwhile to me
was basically a do-gooder I think the
other thing was that I was a
perfectionist and if he said we want
this to be the best damn book that's
ever been written I said I don't I'm not
sure that I could deliver that but if he
says doesn't matter I said sure I'll go
ahead and try in other words after 10
years I thought I'd made enough
connections between theory and practice
so I went ahead and wrote it and how
many how many lives that's the
incredible thing how many lives have you
touched with that
there are all kinds of scary things if
you want to raise questions like that
there was some very simple ones when it
was first about to be published I
worried about how many children it would
kill you know not because it gave
definitely the wrong advice but or any
kind of advice can be misunderstood and
I was always trying to lean in the
direction of reassuring parents the
easiest thing in the world for a doctor
or for doctor writing a book is too
scared of achievers out of people and
the previous books on child care all
were along the general lines look out
stupid if you don't do exactly what I
say you'll kill your child or at least
make your child very sick I was leaning
over backwards always to be reassuring
but this dangers in being too reassuring
a lot of parents are too anxious with
the first child but by the time they
have got there they're remarkably casual
I was scared
anyway I'm very pleased that after 30
million copies have been sold and used
that nobody's accused me of having a
child the accusations that it corrupts
youth that had come until 22 years after
it was published and that came as a
reaction to my opposition to the war in
Vietnam I think that it was a purely
political act it wasn't it one of the
presidents who said that that we
wouldn't have these demonstrations in
the street and Spock hadn't damaged a
generation children one of the worst
accusers the man who went all over the
United States was Spiro Agnew you
remember that I turned out to be a
common crook and he had the nerve to
tell the American people that I had
corrupted the youth well several people
did argue that you offered more
permissive practices of child rearing
and that created a more
anti-authoritarian generation that
question more that rebelled against the
authority more and that this was part of
the reason for the flower children in
the 1960s the anti-war movement the
feminist movement in all of these
different movements I get on you like I
stopped on city streets and in airports
by people who come up
and thank me for writing the book that
helped them raise two fine children then
they often add and I don't see that it's
permissive and I think that's right it
isn't def permissive I'm incapable of
giving permissive advice if by
permissive you mean let them have
anything they want and let them do
anything they want I very much like
children and who are polite who are
cooperative and I raised my own that way
when my sons are interviewed by the
press of course the poor things are
always asked no what was it like being a
child of your father and they both sober
up right away and say oh he was a stern
father no I think it was if by
permissive you mean understand what
motivates children and tried to use that
motivation to help them to grow up to
become more mature more responsible it's
permissive in this sense but not in the
sense that most people use it which
means brats simply it demeans brats let
it all hang out let it hang out and now
I think that if you want to be serious
about it I think I might have had just a
little bit to do with the independence
of those anti-war young people during
the Vietnam War period because you see
what I was saying to parents is you
don't have to grab your child from birth
and begin molding him sternly right from
the beginning children want more than
anything else in the world to grow up
that's why they practice adult
activities all day long they're trying
to grow up and be more like their
parents and your job is to guide them
because they're inexperienced and
they're impulsive but they will do
nine-tenths of the work and I think what
it did was relax parents and get them to
feel well the child in general is going
to turn try to turn out well if we do a
reasonably good job and to put in
another way I think parents didn't
have to coerce their children or more
specifically intimidate their children I
was constantly intimidated by my mother
made me feel guilty when I used to come
home from school or come in from playing
I cringed as I came in the house what
will my mother scold me about what have
I done wrong I hadn't done anything
wrong but I always felt as if I'd done
wrong well I think that my book helped
parents not to intimidate their children
and the result was children when they
grew up to be youth and decided that the
war was an entirely wrong war
unconstitutional illegal full of war
crimes they had perfect confidence in
just making that decision for themselves
I found it to my own distress when I was
a professor at the Western Reserve
Medical School a couple of years before
I had to retire for age I tried to
intimidate the first-year class because
a third of the class was coming late
this was inconceivable at the time that
I went to medical school I tried several
occasions to intimidate them
I finally thundered at them a little and
I said I meant at last two weeks ago
when I said please come on time or don't
come at all I I raised goose flesh on my
own spine I because it's so unseemly for
a professor to be blundering at students
and I didn't it scared me to hear myself
doing it didn't scare them at all just
as many came late just as many brought
coffee
just as many slumped down during the
lecture sipping their coffee you can't
intimidate them those were sparking kids
yeah I didn't intend it that worked out
like this [ __ ] yeah I think considering
the terrible state of the country in the
terrible state of the world I think it's
great that there are young people who
can't be intimidated can't be made a
compliant I think the only thing that I
feel badly about is that that spirit of
Independence didn't
last you know I asked teachers in high
schools and colleges now what are your
students like and they said all very
docile uh the horrible conforming they
just want to get good grades and go on
and get a good job so obviously I didn't
make any deep dent and the young another
reason for not accusing me of corrupting
a whole generation was that all the
conservative youths that did go to
Vietnam and never protested they were
raised by my brother so dr. sparks some
people have claimed that you change
radically your child-rearing methods and
theories over the years his is true of
you basically started sensible that was
a complete misunderstanding a press
report went out from Redbook magazine
boosting one of my articles and it was
poorly expressed and it was
misinterpreted especially by those
people who assumed that I was a
permissive is that I was that i turned
against permissiveness I never was a
permissive estándar turned against it
though I've changed my mind about how to
help mothers breastfeed and about
inoculations and things like that and
those have grown into the revisions and
then also tried to get rid of the sexism
and that was part of the book and the
beginning I'd never have changed my
basic feeling that children are very
decent people let us start with that
they trying to become a more mature and
the parents job is to give them guidance
to give them respect but to ask for
respect from them I mean this this is
where parents some parents have gotten
into trouble they're so ashamed of the
abuse of children and the oppression of
children in past periods that they jump
to the opposite extreme and have the
feeling parents are apt to do the wrong
thing children are right and they almost
become apologetic to their children or
submissive to their children respect
children but ask for respect from them
that's the hard thing for many people to
do well dr. sparke during the 1950's you
became a household world and a word in
America because of your child caring and
we're in techniques then suddenly you
became a political figure during the
1960's the beginning of this was your
entrance into Seine was it not what led
you to become concerned about nuclear
weapons and to join that group that was
opposing it was purely a pediatric issue
as far as I was concerned that the
director of saying had twice invited me
to join in the previous three years and
I told him no I don't know anything
about fallout and I've always been a
reassure of parents I don't want to
start in scaring parents about radiation
he very smartly came back a third time
and said he still thought that I ought
to be part of the committee and I was
finally convinced but if we don't have a
test ban treaty and that was the issue
that Sain was particularly concerned
about them test ban treaty to be
negotiated between the United States and
the Soviet Union we don't have that more
and more children around the world will
die of cancer and leukemia or be born
with mental and physical defects as a
result of fallout radiation from fallout
so I joined sane
became co-chairman a year later and had
to become a spokesman for disarmament
but I saw it as a pediatric issue wasn't
the medical evidence accumulating during
that period that indeed the fallout from
the tests were causing cancer Barry
commoner wrote a book and I think 1959
science and common sense the documented
this in a popular way right as the years
have gone by the experts on radiation of
kept having to revise their standards
down and down in the sense of finding
that less and less radiation is harmful
to human beings and they've come to the
conclusion there is no part no amount of
radiation so small that it doesn't
affect at least a few individuals and
that's why I've become
only an opponent of nuclear weapons but
of nuclear power - we still can't say
that it's safe to allow nuclear power
plants to exist and to be leaking very
small amounts of radiation constantly
and that's what they're all doing dr.
Spock it was quite a jump then just from
that medical aspect to being anti-war in
the Vietnam era what caused you to jump
that to the link there was that I joined
saying in 62 and in 64 I was asked by
Lyndon Johnson's campaign committee to
support him on radio and television and
I said I certainly would because Lyndon
Johnson promised in that campaign he
would not send American boys to fight in
an Asian war those were his words
whereas Barry Goldwater was threatening
a destruction of Vietnam just wipe it
off the face of the earth
so I said certainly I'll support him as
a citizen and as a pediatrician and as a
spokesman for the disarmament movement
and I did enough so that he called me up
two days after the election to thank me
and he said dr. sparke I hope I proved
worthy of your trust I had no idea I had
no idea that he'd prove only unworthy of
my trust as far as me as far as Vietnam
was concerned and ice I can still
remember saying Oh President Johnson of
course you'll be worthy of my trust he
only waited three months from November
64 until Feb first week of February 65
when he suddenly started the bombing of
North Vietnam and the build-up of
fighting troops that eventually reached
half a million I was horrified and I was
outraged and this was just
well I became more and rapidly I became
more and more active accepted more and
more invitations to speak against the
war which I saw as totally abominable
and evident in every way
there was no redeeming feature to it at
all was there something big that
happened there's another big bridge to
cross from opposite from disagreement to
active opposition and particularly civil
disobedience was there something
dramatic that happened there was just a
gradual escalation well in one sense it
was a gradual escalation I think that
certainly Lyndon Johnson starting the
bombing was the first shock and outrage
that I got that precipitated me into
much more action and then three years
later I was I and three other people for
other people including the chaplain of
Yale University were indicted by the
Johnson administration
they said for conspiracy to counsel aid
and abet resistance to the military
draft I was just trying to stop the war
in Vietnam by telling the American
people work against it tell the
president tell your Senators tell your
Congressman
we were tried we were convicted
we were sentenced to two years in jail
fortunately to a year later the Federal
Court of Appeals reversed the decision
so I didn't have to serve any time on
that rap though I I did for the first
time in my life experience the inside of
a jail I spent a night in jail six or
eight that times as a result of civil
disobedient demonstrations when I first
heard of civil disobedience as a weapon
to to use against the war it scared me I
was brought up to be extremely
law-abiding as a child I was terrified
of the cop on the Block though I never
did anything wrong
I never did ride my bike on the sidewalk
I never did go out on Halloween so it
was a real
tremendous distance for me to commit
civil disobedience even to be in
demonstrations was very embarrassing at
first I cringed and reporters would come
up and shove a microphone in my face and
say have you been protesting a night
what in the Soviet Union has been doing
and when I heard about other people
committing civil disobedience I'd get
goose flesh right away and think that's
not for me I'm that may be
counterproductive but as the years of
opposing the war went on and I saw that
civil disobedience was drawing attention
to the outrage was convincing a lot of
people that that it was the wrong war I
II was willing to do civil disobedience
also but I must say it was painful the
first couple of times some of the forms
of civil disobedience what was your
first act of civil disobedience what are
some of the other sitting down and in
New York City on the steps of the
induction Center it was purely symbolic
we got together with the police
department beforehand and we had a talk
with the mayor about it and it was all
agreed that was purely symbolic and
there were about 2,000 demonstrators in
New York City that morning five o'clock
in the morning if you're going to be
there when the inductees come in it's
five o'clock in the morning it was it
wasn't even light yet I can still
remember how scary it was there were
5,000 the cops there surrounding the
induction Center in 2000
well-intentioned demonstrators and I
could tell you a long story about trying
to climb over the barricades trying to
crawl under the barricades finally
finding a [ __ ] in the barricades to get
in and just sit down on the steps of the
induction Center it was symbolic
obstruction to the war mission to the
war machine and then the cop comes up
and says if you don't remove yourself
I'll arrest you and you pretend you
don't here and he just takes you by the
elbow and escorts you to the paddy wagon
and off you go to jail and
it's the it's the boredom of jail
hour after hour after hour nothing to
read nothing to do and just a frozen
salami sandwich to eat after you've been
there about eight or ten hours well it's
not a terrible suffering to spend the
night in jail but I often wonder how
anybody could stand it for a week let
alone a year or ten years you had you
made attempts to get through to and
talked with LBJ again did you not either
orally or in writing and also with
without for Humphrey also did you know I
wrote that many letters to Johnson
pointing out not only that the war was
wrong from every point of view but it
was unwinnable I think I had a bit of a
nerve to be so absolutely sure it was
unwinnable I said it was unwinnable
because the French had found it
unwinnable they tried to fight the
Vietnamese for eight years and were
ignominiously I defeated and I thought
that probably pointed the finger toward
us too well I wrote letters accusing him
of not only illegalities and authorizing
the war crimes but also telling him you
know if you go on with this the American
people will turn more and more against
it you'll end up by turning the country
over to the Republicans I thought that
would get to him even if the illegality
didn't how did he respond to any of
these oh the trouble was of course that
an assistant would always answer most
often McGeorge Bundy who was a pretty
high assistant and I think the president
would have done well to leave my letters
unanswered because the the letters from
McGeorge Bundy were the most
condescending and therefore the most
irritating letter that I've ever gotten
in my life
general spirit of all of them was my
dear doctor you may be sure we've
brought up what you're talking about but
we found that it's without demerit yours
sincerely and I'd sit down and write
another letter to the President and fine
I wrote one with an enclosed note to
Jack Valenti who was one of his
assistants saying mr. Valenti will you
put this letter on his desk so that if
he wants to he can read it I want to
know that the president knows how I feel
about what he did to the people who
voted for him as the peace candidate
that did it I got a note from the
President himself
I'd accused him of 10 crimes and one of
them I didn't have solid ground and he
picked up that tenth one was a
unwinnable and not the non winnable one
because he couldn't prove that it was
winnable but I said that he sprung that
on the country by bombing North Vietnam
oh that's right and he pointed out that
he'd threatened retaliation both at The
Associated Press convention in April of
64 and in the Tonkin Gulf Resolution of
the summer of 64 that he'd threatened
retaliation so he had me I was a little
bit embarrassed to have over overreached
myself in the accusations but I noticed
that he didn't touch the other two six
well then what about Hubert Humphrey it
looked like there was a chance that he
might he would have the opportunity to
wind down the war but he didn't what
kind of a person was he not - well I've
cost thought that uh Hubert Humphrey who
I'd always believed was a fairly strong
liberal would be opposed to the war and
after I couldn't get to the president
with my letters I wrote to Hubert
Humphrey that I've met on a number of
times in the past sort of hinting around
that wasn't it terrible what the
president was doing to himself to the
American people and to the Democratic
Party and I was rather shocked I think
he would have done better not to answer
my letter of course he couldn't say
Spock you're right there Lyndon Johnson
is wrong but he could have at least said
I can understand your distress or
something like that but he wrote me back
a total justification for the war and
this was quite a shock to me because in
a mild way he was a hero of mine
was his relationship with Johnson was
was it so was he under such control or
intimidation by Johnson that he couldn't
break out later when he was running well
I thought that was the strangest thing
about Humphrey of all in the first place
Johnson had to give up the presidency
had to say I will not run again he
didn't say because I made a mess of
Vietnam nobody said to reunite the
American people behind the government
and then he anointed Hubert Humphrey to
be a successor and to have the
nomination amend this incredible
business of insisting that Hubert
Humphrey run on the total support of the
war in Vietnam that had already
destroyed Johnson I thought
extraordinary that Johnson asked them to
- to run on the same Vietnam platform
and I thought extraordinary that Hubert
Humphrey agreed to do so because he
broke out of the traces just a little
bit and his popularity began coming up
but it wasn't enough to prevent the
election of Nixon didn't you also get
involved in politics with different
groups and I even remember seeing you on
television talking about running in a
presidential election could you say a
few words about that of how that related
to some your anti-war well you see I'd
been a Liberal Democrat from the time I
was in medical school until the Vietnam
War began but those experiences
radicalized me I realized our government
and its foreign policy is more often
than not aggressive that it's trying to
extend the power of our armed services
or trying to extend the markets of our
industries in other words it's the
government is not working as much for
the welfare of the American people as
it's working for the for industry and
for its own their power so I became a
radical and and I became a socialist and
then in 1971 a number of small socialist
groups in different parts of the country
most notably the P
freedom party in California got together
there were about 10 or 12 local parties
there was one in Texas Florida there was
the human rights party in Michigan there
was the party in Washington DC the
states rights party in Washington DC
they all got together decided to be an
association and then to form a National
Party and to run a national candidate
and I was the candidate people say why
did you run I didn't particularly want
to run I mean it was not my picture of
myself but it was a great there was a
strong sentiment obviously because I was
well-known and a party that doesn't have
any members to start with and it doesn't
have any money to start with and it
doesn't have any prospect of getting any
money it needs something so they wanted
a candidate who was known so I consent
it it was very educational
we got about 80,000 votes but we'd only
gotten on the ballot in ten states it's
called the People's Party I campaigned
all over the United States at my onyx
this was 1972 this was 72 72 campaign
and I had good-sized audience as usually
at universities one of the things I
realized was how far Americans are from
really considering socialism in fact as
you know most Americans are scared to
death of the word socialism it
immediately conjures up pictures of
secret police and destruction of
churches and trying to Akaka because all
socialism means is producing things for
the benefit of people rather than for
profit and I think it's a perfectly
reasonable and agile philosophy and our
party was strongly Democratic in the
sense that we believed it should be
brought in through the democratic
process and that it must stay Democratic
be controlled by the people after it was
in
I speak to an enthusiastic audience and
then always you know a couple of dozen
people come up on the platform and one
of the things that I've been talking
about the whole hour of talk and a whole
hour of answering questions was don't
worry about whether you're voting for
Democrats or Republicans both of them
are controlled by industry the
personalities are different Nixon is
different from McGovern but the policies
that you'll get will be exactly the same
always one of the people who goes up on
the platform this happened every single
night for a year and was terribly
discouraging the repetition they say
great speech you've got me convinced
we've gotta have a different economic
system but of course I can't vote for
you because I wouldn't want to waste my
vote mm he was somebody in two hours at
theme and have it absolutely clear that
he's missed the point altogether of
course what really is that what it
really amounts to is especially with
undergraduates they're pretty strongly
identified with the system and though
there may be a little recession here or
a big depression there I think they in
general in America have confidence that
they're going to be able to make out all
right I think it's simply a statement
socialism sounds fair and sounds sort of
nice but don't ask me to give up my
stake in the present economy because I
expect to do quite well well they always
they said to you and a lot of people
during the 60s and early 70s now you got
to work within the system dr. Spock
don't go outside the system but is it
even possible to work within the system
and make any meaningful change well I
think that the power is of course all on
the part of the establishment and on the
part of industry and on the part of the
government and that people who have any
strong protest have an uphill fight it
certainly was an uphill fight to try to
win a majority of the American people
over to opposition to the war in Vietnam
though it was it was done in the
I always worked within the system I
wrote letters to every politician that
represent me I participated in political
campaigns always voted I wrote letters
to the paper I went to peaceful
demonstrations but I think if after you
find that the press is paying no
attention to you which is true I mean
you could have maybe one demonstration
that was peaceful the press would report
it but after you've had that third or
the fourth or the fifth they get bored
they say that's not news that a few
thousand people are shuffling around the
White House again there's no question
about it that civil disobedience
dramatizes your opposition it's saying I
feel so strongly that the government is
wrong that I'm willing to go to jail if
necessary in order to make this point
and you do reach people that way so the
press suddenly pays attention lest just
a year ago I and my wife and about ten
of the people from the health
professions demonstrated at the White
House we knelt down on the White House
lawn to pray and that's against the law
and we were protesting against cuts in
health services by the Reagan
administration and with course we were
immediately arrested but there were both
Washington papers had half a page on it
with pictures and Newsweek magazine had
a quarter of a page on it I I wouldn't
do it foolishly a fool in a foolhardy
way but there's no question that it's a
way of bringing the issue to the people
dr. sparke in your travels particularly
in the last ten years when you've been
working with these anti-nuclear groups
and other political groups you see more
of a consciousness that the political
problems of America are not just single
issue issues like for instance and in
the Vietnam War ending nuclear energy
but there's more radical systemic
changes that need to be brought about do
you think more and more people are
beginning to see
this well most of these political groups
just focused on this one issue well I
think the traditional parties are get
concerned about relatively secondary
issues like should you should you
decrease the budget or should you
increase the budget and things like that
my feeling is of course that the very
fundamental changes have got to be made
that we've got to have a less
competitive more cooperative society and
I think there's a growing number of
people who feel that way but what
discourages me is that we have to have
either a terrible war like the war in
Vietnam to make the American people wake
up that something fundamental is wrong
or we have to have an administration
like the Reagan administration that is
getting into what I call an insane
acceleration of the arms race and
hurting the American people especially
poor people disadvantaged people by
cutting down on health services cutting
down on educational services welfare
services housing all the things that I
think are important for people are being
being impaired and what it's too bad
they have to have a war in Vietnam or a
policy as drastically wrong as I
consider Reagan's a policy before any
substantial number of people will wake
up and at least wake up enough to become
active in any way I think we've got some
kind of a tradition in this country of
indifference to the political process I
think a lot of Americans say listen
politics is a dirty business don't pay
any attention your job is to go out and
get a good job and get ahead in the
world no I think everybody's job is to
get a good job I also think that
everything's got to be argued on the
political stage also you see a third
party as the vehicle for the sort of
change that you're talking about it
there any third parties like the
Citizens party today that you're
impressed with well I think sooner or
later from my point of view that's got
to be a strong
party and a people lot to the left end
of the spectrum I've got to get together
behind it but I don't see any in it but
the number are increasing but I don't
think that it's a very substantial
number yet I have hopes and I'll
continue to work work work as long as I
can stay upright I'll keep on working
but Jay